as infection rates go up the police
are cracking down with threats of
further fines
and a plea from politicians i support
the police in doing
their very difficult job which they're
doing very sensitively
but they're also right to take very
seriously the rules we've brought in you
know we haven't brought them in because
we wanted to we've brought them in
because we've had to
um and every flexibility could be fatal
because if you just say i'll just flex
this bit of the rules the problem is
this virus is so contagious
it then passes on and then as we've seen
it is
deadly and there are there are there are
people dying
every day and the nhs has got this
enormous pressure on it like it's never
seen before
but is there public appetite for tougher
restrictions i feel
they're as high as they can be and if
you want to ignore it you ignore it
as long as it protects me i'm happy with
it
look at other countries that have the
way they've handled certain situations
we're too slow meanwhile england's chief
medical officer has made one of his
starkest warnings yet
writing in the sunday times chris
whitsey said the nhs in some parts of
the country
is currently facing the most dangerous
situation anyone can remember
there will be avoidable deaths nhs staff
are doing their absolute best
and working remarkably we all owe them a
huge debt of gratitude
but even they have limits every
unnecessary interaction you have could
be the link in the chain of transmission
which has a vulnerable person at the end
but labor argue part of the problem is
the government's mixed messages
i think the vast majority of the british
public have been complying throughout
they've been working really hard and
it's been a real struggle
the problem has been the government's
mis mixed messages
you know eat out don't eat out go back
to work don't go to bat
to work stay you know stay at home don't
stay at home the central message now
is critically important stay home save
lives and protect our nhs
covert vaccinations are now being
delivered at a rate of 200
000 a day and the government say every
adult will be offered one
by the autumn but scientists argue that
on its own
is not enough we should not be in this
position next winter we should not be
having thousands of deaths as well as
being in a
lockdown and having health services near
collapse so work back from where we want
to be next winter which is in a good
position
look at countries that are in that
position and then figure out what are
the things we need to do
over the next 10 to 12 months to get
there and i think that will involve
having to really fix our test and trace
system get on top of border measures
actually have a strategy beyond saying
this is a seasonal infection we're going
to deal with
whatever some scientists say ministers
are clear they don't want to reimpose
restrictions next winter
yet they concede to achieve that they'll
need more than the current vaccination
program
but a roll-out as with flu every single
year
negotiating our way through waves of the
virus is likely to become a permanent
part
of everyday life joe pike sky news